another victim in the attack on a
wisconsin holiday parade over the
weekend an eight-year-old has now died
the sixth person to lose their life in
this tragedy more than 60 others were
injured and the suspect is now charged
with murder elise preston has the story
more criminal charges are likely for the
man accused of plowing his suv through
the waukesha christmas parade on sunday
the nature of this offense is shocking
during an initial court appearance for
the alleged driver daryl brooks
prosecutors said another victim had
succumbed to his injuries today we
learned of another death of a child
related to this case
we do expect a sixth count for first
degree intentional homicide to be issued
the complaint says brooks appeared to
intentionally target people even as he
swerved to avoid other vehicles bail was
set at 5 million dollars
video recorded by a doorbell camera
shows the suspect outside a house
shortly after the incident hey can i
call some i caught an uber and i'm
supposed to be waiting for it over here
but i don't know when it's coming the
homeowner was unaware of what happened
at the parade and allowed brooks to use
his cell phone he was telling me that oh
is there something going on downtown i
was like uh there's a parade today i
know but he's like oh that's probably
what is a parade
so he was just completely putting on a
face and lying about everything the
video later shows police arriving at the
scene and taking brooks into custody if
convicted he could face life in prison
elise preston cbs news